bonsoir françois choffat en 6 merci de
répondre à nos questions cette prise
d'otage si elle est avérée est ce que
c'est un acte de représailles aux
actions militaires françaises dans la
région du sahel où se situe le mali où
opèrent l'armée française avec
l'opération barkan neurones c'est un
moyen de pression
accoutumé des groupes terroristes
d'ailleurs qu'ils soient dans le sahel
ou ailleurs on prend en otage on le
modèle du mieux possible
on cherche à perturber un petit peu ce
qui se passe voilà je dirais que non ce
n'est pas une mesure de représailles
parce que ça ne changera pas grand chose
non je crois qu'on est sur un rapt
presque crapuleux et je crois qu'il faut
pas le voir autrement c'est à dire qu'il
va y avoir une demande de rançon il
paraît que ça ne se fait pas donc
peut-être que ça se fera mais on ne le
saura pas je dirais que ma position
quand j'entends effectivement une prise
d'otage de ce type d'un journaliste je
veux bien croire que le journaliste à 2
doit aller chercher l'information mais
quand on est dans une zone d'insécurité
une zone de guerre
on fait attention et je considère quand
même parce qu'on ne sait pas la première
fois qu'on est dans ces situations là ce
n'est pas parce qu'ils ont des
journalistes quand on est en situation
d'impunité où je dirais de protéger avec
des gens comme al qaïda et consorts ce
sont des groupes qui n'ont aucun respect
pour les journalistes
donc quand on commence à prendre contact
avec eux il faut pas s'étonner que ça
dérape donc vous dénoncez un geste d'
imprudence d'olivier dubois si il est
vraiment a pris en otage c'est une bonne
question
vous savez bien que si je dis qu'il a
fait à la tonhalle prudence tout de
suite tout le monde dira nord il a pris
toutes les précautions qu'il fallait je
veux bien le croire mais pour l'instant
il est en otage il a émis le souhait
d'être récupéré au bout d'un mois nous
avons eu en afghanistan il ya quelques
années
il ya des zones dangereuses de
journalistes et pas intouchable c'est
une monnaie d'échangé très intéressante
pour les groupes terroristes
un journaliste doit comprendre que même
s'il doit aller chercher l'information
il ya des moments où il faut faire
attention il s'était fait piéger c'est
ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui c'est aussi je
pense le contre argument pour dire qu'il
appelait de ses précautions
il a fait confiance
peut-être dans tous les cas aujourd'hui
les pluies en otage et ça va durer sans
doute un certain temps et de quel levier
stratégique peut user paraît d'ailleurs
bamako importante est de faire libérer
olivier dubois je pense qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup
puisqu'on va rien céder sur le terrain
on ne va rien céder sur barkan
on ne va rien céder sur notre politique
étrangère peut être qu'il y aura une
action indirecte par le gouvernement
malien comme il l'a fait précédemment
mais je rappellerai que la position de
paris est très clair nous ne négocions
pas avec les terroristes
c'est un groupe terroriste nous ne
négocierons pas avec eux maintenant il
ne faut pas être naïf
on tâchera toujours de le ramener
peut-être tout dépend de la maison ça va
se passer donc on peut supposer que des
médiateurs intermédiaires se proposeront
où seront envoyées sans doute par le
gouvernement malien en octobre plus de
200 prisonniers dont de nombreux
jihadistes ont été libérés par les
autorités maliennes en échange de la
libération de quatre otages dont la
française sophie petrona est-ce que
c'était une erreur est ce que ce n'a pas
renforcé l'instabilité secure et de
sécurité sécuritaire dans laquelle se
trouve le mali oui tout à fait d'abord
je pense que il me semble que le présent
mâcon s'est exprimé sur la question
le gouvernement français a été
extrêmement j'irai chagriné de 7 de sa
libération puisqu'ils y avait des
djihadistes avéré qu'ils ont été libérés
oui on a récupéré madame petrona qui
s'est dépêché de dire qu'ils étaient
prêts à retourner au mali
il y a un problème je dirais simplement
que quand on commence à négocier avec
des terroristes et c'est valable pour
toutes les guerres quels que soient les
pays
nous sommes confrontés à ajdir est une
forme de chantage avec l'esp est
humaniste humanitaire d'un côté
vis-à-vis des personnes enlevées
l'autre côté les questions politiques
pour l'instant ceux qui prient me
semble-t-il au niveau français c'est la
ligne politique et je pense que les
otages ne sont qu' un petit élément de
la question aujourd'hui du sahel et du
mali donc je ne serai pas 13 j'irai
optimiste sur un retour prochain de ce
journaliste sauf si des arrangements
qu'on ne connaît pas son prix georges
malbrunot et christian
et nous en 2004 en irak sophie petrona
ou olivier dubois donc au mali plus
récemment pour ne citer que vous avez
évoqué l'afghanistan
tout à l'heure les ressortissants
français reste une cible des jihadistes
quelle est la menace aujourd'hui
réellement quelles sont les
recommandations également du quai
d'orsay
le quai d'orsay dans tous les cas dit
n'allez pas dans les zones dangereuses
c'est sur son site s'est dit
régulièrement en effet que ce n'est que
répéter et là je reviens peut être un
débat plus général sur le comportement
du citoyen français
le citoyen français au même titre que
hier ou aujourd'hui les citoyens
américains sont des cibles des groupes
extrémistes et ils savent que les
campagnes de presse peuvent soutenir une
libération que une campagne de presse
pour cette libération est capable
d'obtenir quelques résultats en faisant
pression par l'opinion publique ce qui
varie de moins en moins bien donc
effectivement on a on a un problème et
le sens des responsabilités par rapport
à sa liberté d'aller informer d'aller
chercher l'information se pose c'est
valable pour beaucoup d'autres sujets de
société la liberté s'arrête un moment
donné quand sa sécurité est en danger
dans un premier temps et dans un
deuxième temps que la sécurité des
autres est engagé rappelez vous ces deux
otages
nous sommes allés rechercher au burkina
ils nous ont coûté la vie de deux
sous-officiers et bakoko vois ça va je
regrette j'estime que l'aïe une attitude
irresponsable de personnes qui sont
allées dans une zone d'opérations
dangereuses où il faudrait peut-être
aller les rechercher
merci françois chavance y est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général de brigade et expert
en géostratégie